is the smart to specialize or generalize
your a lot of people talking about the
way to go right now is to generalize not
specialize today we're gonna talk about
when it makes sense to specialize and
when it makes sense to generalize to
generalize or to specialize that's the
question we can answer here today by the
way we're gonna talk about Amazon Nike
and uber but prior to doing that I'll
explain why phases matter when it comes
down to the topic of generalization or
specialization and on my story look for
me when you think about getting involved
with my business I got into financial
services a day before 9/11 would Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter I got my series 7
license which allows me to sell stocks
bonds mutual funds money under
management I've got my 66 31 which
allows you to sell futures and
commodities and in 26 which allows me to
manage it in a life and age with a life
and help which allows me to sell
insurance health insurance all these
other products right so when I first
went to Morgan I was selling a ton of
different products then I went to trance
I still was selling a lot of different
products many different products so you
have to learn how to sell mutual funds
how to fill out paper works here and
it's at the beginning stages of it when
I started my own insurance company till
today I'm still slicing with all of
these licenses till today but I decided
to specifically focus on specialization
for the following reason I got rid of
stocks bonds mutual funds I got rid of
ETFs money under management I got rid of
very real annuities I got rid of 529
college education plans one mistake we
made at one point is we brought in
merchant accounts saying hey merchant
account is a great product to sell
within our company I notice my agents
who were trying to learn how to sell
annuities and we're trying to learn how
to sell insurance we're spending way too
much time selling merchant accounts that
were going to the business owner they
were trying to set up the machine there
was complications for $38 a month for
$59 a month and created so many
headaches because we were generalizing
so I'll emanated this I eliminated loans
I eliminated realist
they know auto insurance no
modifications no health insurance
nothing life annuities is what we did
why here's why there's few phases you go
through as a company
you got survival phase you got
formulation phase you're putting the
pieces together you got momentum phase
then at a point you're gonna Plateau
okay when you're during the survival
phase you can't afford to do a lot of
different products you can't afford to
sell a lot of different products because
focus is the key and it's being lost
even during form formulation you cannot
you're trying to get your guys going
when you're going to momentum and now
you grow and now you've developed
leaders now you've developed in them
independent machines that are running by
themselves then you can consider looking
elsewhere right before you Plateau what
do I mean by this let's transition over
to Amazon Amazon starts up with books
people say Amazon sells everything today
it's not how they got started so you
can't say I'm gonna be Amazon we at our
company or like Amazon we sell
everything you can't say that if you're
at this face because you confuse people
you can say that when you're Amazon at
the last face not at the beginning face
Amazon start selling books then they
sell DVDs then they sell toys why are
you selling toys people want to buy toys
they team up with Toys R Us then he
censures
then today Amazon sells everything what
do you want you want to do Amazon Prime
movies you want cloud you want to host
you want a media you want to Washington
Post what do you want they now do
everything but can you imagine if they
try to go get Washington Post your
Amazon Prime here on how hosting any no
it's not gonna work out there's phases
to the game Nike they first start out by
importing shoes they didn't even make
shoes that first
shoes came in they sold it wholesale
retail then they said why don't we make
our own shoes so then they made their
own shoes what kind of shoes do we make
do we make dress shoes do we make shoes
for soccer players do we make shoes for
basketball players they just focus on
running shoes
let's make running shoes guess what this
guy named Michael's coming out what
about if we really put some money into
this Michael guy you know he didn't like
there's a converse because converse is
you being ran with Magic Johnson Larry
Bird and everybody's with
converse he really likes adidas but
their presentation wasn't good and they
couldn't afford to pay Michael money
here's our opportunity Nike let's give
them big money they give him big money
then Nike went from importing shoes
making running shoes basketball soccer
and then look at what conglomerate of
Nikes turn into because they went from
specializing to then generalizing if you
go to a Nike store today you can a
basketball track running baseball cleats
it doesn't matter
they're now everywhere let's look at the
last one yours uber uber starts out it
starts off with what passengers in one
small city then a state then a region
then a country then another country then
ubereats then uber transportation
freight and uber so they are now
evolving if they would have tried to do
move number nineteen that move number
one they would have gone out of business
this is why I wrote the book your next
five moves because everything is about
sequencing everything is about
sequencing this because Amazon sequence
of doing business was right that's why
they're a behemoth today because Jeff
Bezos gets credit for knowing what moves
came next you don't think he thought
about what he was eventually gonna do
you don't think when he's sitting by
himself realized that how many books
he's selling he's sitting there saying
what else can we sell what other market
can we take out you don't think they're
thinking about that of course they're
thinking about that you think Netflix is
done doing what they're doing right now
you think this is it for Netflix you
think Netflix is done what they're doing
you don't think there's additional
things that Netflix is gonna be coming
out with but it's about sequencing so
for many people out there that read
books oh my gosh
multiple streams of income this is what
I gotta do I gotta go out and do this
and for so many you know gurus out there
that are saying you look at what
Amazon's doing look at what these guys
are they sell everything that medicine
they're right they are selling
everything under the Sun in their
industry but they're doing it at this
phase
not at this phase this is why I wrote
the book your next five moves which is
coming out August 18 if you haven't yet
purchased the book I'm gonna leave the
link below for you to go get the book
your next five moves so again going back
to it if you're a startup if you're
barely doing your business if you're
just you know one year two years three
years five years
make a list of all the products you sell
and one by one by one start eliminating
them one by one by one by one by one
eliminating them to feel worse stay
focused today then go wide with a ton of
market share of what you doing with
those two three products and then say
here's next here's next here's next
don't do it all simultaneous though or
else you will lose momentum and you may
never make it to this space because you
may go out of business here or here if
you try to do everything too early
having said that I got two videos I want
you to watch one of them there's a
multiple streams of income the myth
about multiple streams of income if
you've never watches click over here to
watch this the other one is the
comparison I made between Walmart and
Amazon why Walmart is about to be David
going against Goliath Amazon meaning
Walmart has the potential of taking out
Amazon if you've not seen that click
over here to watch that video and again
if you haven't purchased the book your
next five moves click below to all the
order to book your next five moves and
if you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
[Music]